hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play outlast
okay let's get to it we need to get
to the security control room which i'm
assuming is gonna allow me to open the
front doors
and then go on my merry way and enjoy
the rest of my life
in peace and solitude nothing bad's
gonna happen
yep that's what i thought uh oh oh hi
dexter thanks so much you're gonna put
me on a table
i didn't want to have to do this to you
you sound sorry but you can't leave
not yet oh there's so much yet
for you to witness like your ugly face
it's pretty nice
can you yeah maybe you could witness a
toothbrush into your mouth
oh the only way out of this place is the
truth
what accept the gospel and all doors
will open before you
if you say so man how is that even a
thing
was that in the present or was that in
the past were more soldiers coming in or
was that when they got murdered before
i'm gonna assume that was in the past
there
so this wall rider of yours is some
ghosty goo
that can tear people apart from the
inside why did that remind me of fear
you guys remember in uh like fear one
didn't it wasn't that a thing like
those soldiers got dragged around and
immortalized
i have no idea but in this asylum there
seems to be a lot of you know
psychobabble uh experiments going on to
try to make people oh at least he left
me my camera
i'm so grateful for that living my life
through a lens
just like everything else in my
journalistic ways
no not jay note the priest father martin
brought me here to show me something
thinks i'm going to be a witness for
whatever bat [ __ ] crazy he's trying to
sell me
this dr wernick is wernicke is at the
center of whatever went wrong here but
he died more than 10 years ago
rest in peace says the blood on the wall
one not gonna go for the joke rest in
pieces
okay can i get out of here no what oh hi
hey thanks so much buddy
wow you're so great get the [ __ ] away
from me
whoa whoa whoa there buddy
all right so that guy's kind of going
nutso bonkers okay i'm gonna assume that
most of these doors are locked
uh this one's probably locked too yes
most definitely okay so i need to go the
other way
oh boy i've been with all the crazy
people again this looks so weird because
occasionally
it'll throw me in with these people and
i'm assuming they're not going to attack
me
maybe i'm just going to check these
doors just in case i'm assuming that
they're
maybe i won't check the doors hey how's
it going there you want a high five
bro hi oh
you're so beautiful what do you do to
keep that incredible complexion
nothing i can't believe it
oh hi did you enjoy your meal
ah you've gone and made a mess
oh you're even more beautiful than the
last one
okay what does this wall rider do to
these guys that makes them all
like uh
oh hello you look different i would like
to kill him
oh no thank you
come on now let's be here yeah yeah the
preacher
definitely impolite we give him a
running start there's an idea
and when we kill him we kill him
i'm right here guys i'm right such such
patience
and liver they are yours
well glad you're all being so polite
about this you're very civil oh my god
i didn't i didn't mean to look down
oh they're naked they are so naked
oh my god
oh aren't you just hilarious friend
okay so oh they were so
very naked okay there's only one open
door here
so i'm assuming there's something in
here that i need something
left mouse button to hide i guess i can
hide under the bed but that doesn't seem
like a very good spot
okay how about the one with light coming
out of it something here
okay no okay ah here's another open one
anything in here anything okay nothing
in here
okay um let's see here
ah here we go got an open one what's in
here
hello hello hello hello okay there's
absolutely nothing in here that just
says hide okay well
all right then i'm guessing i need to uh
open every other doors yeah i'm curious
why those two guys
hi where'd you come from whoa
what is wrong with your face
oh my god you
ah i'm not even gonna say oh hello guy
were you just walking around bashing
your head
whoa whoa hey whoa hey whoa there you
just calm down okay we got another open
door come on
oh hi sorry were you sleeping
let me just hide under your bed oh no
monsters under here
oh you're gonna rest easy little billy
oh you no you're not billy there's
actually a billy in here i can't call
people billy
oh he's in the last door of course it's
in the last door
where else would it be
what do you say man
hey buddy how's it going friend where'd
you come from
goddamn sicko oh whoa whoa
you like to watch you like to watch what
you're sick i'm sick i'm sorry oh sorry
i didn't mean to
interrupt your dead body fun happiness
you uh
you just carry on i apologize for being
such a weirdo sicko freako
all right almost out of batteries but i
think i'll be okay
hey what i uh what
hey hey hi don't you run away from me
i'm trying to talk to you
you get back here please i do believe
you're trying
to tell me something this might have
been important or not okay
so i i do need to be careful about my
battery consumption i mean i've got
enough oh
look a dead body oh great
was he holding on to a picture of his
family before it got shattered to pieces
all right okay okay i'm back to where i
was before so i need to ledge over
those those giant naked guys oh good
they're not there anymore yeah yeah you
show that wall what's up with your face
yeah good job man keep it up you're
doing great
if they want to get out yeah sure they
are oh you
didn't wait until i finished what but i
saved some for you
just wait i don't think i want to wait
all right then god annoys oh god always
provides a way follow the blood
all right then what is this a
decontamination chamber
or a death kill room
not just a kill room a death kill room
okay so
okay got locked so i can't go back on
something
under the stairs aha there actually is
something under the stairs there are
almost
never something under the stairs yay
okay so now i need to swap out the
batteries
let's see here
down the drain oh good good thing the
arrows are in blood are here
hi
if you say so man i'm gonna go get this
first okay what do we got here
dr zeichner gave me your info to contact
regarding the cancellation of the arts
program my patient martin arkembaud
has made enormous strides in his therapy
on account of the finger painting just
in the weeks since canceling the arts
program
schizo effective assertions of some
higher calling have accelerated
enormously
please just let the man finger paint the
few dollars you're saving on temper
paint is more than swallowed by the cost
of clozapine
i can't imagine the logic at play here
unless murkoff wants our patients to
become more disengaged from reality
okay so it seems like they were
canceling programs that made the
patients
more sane looks like they wanted to
drive people
insane which i think kind of didn't help
them because they're all dead
okay so what do we got here experiments
they were
rituals a conjuring of
what of what man a conjuring of what
okay whatever you know these guys are
just going to give me little hints as i
go through the game
all right anything here anything here
anything here i'm clicking i'm clicking
i'm clicking
doesn't seem like there's anything here
okay carrying on
so i think this is another
decontamination thing i need to get that
open
i don't know how though shut up let me
thank for a minute
whoa whoa
whoa oh
is that another patrolling dude i think
that's another
patrolling dude
hey buddy how's it going over there how
you doing
nice uh blood spray you finger painting
wink wink
okay so i got hidey holes just in case
he comes for me that's blocked up
i will be so quiet i'll be so quiet for
you
okay so that guy doesn't seem like he's
coming after me it's so weird because
i'm like
in the middle of all these guys i don't
know which ones are gonna kill me and
which ones are just gonna say hi to me
actually i'm gonna just assume that all
of them are gonna kill me at some point
it's just that right now some of them
aren't so crazy
okay that's locked oh i'll be
so quiet for you so quiet
so quiet
is that me breathing or is there
something in here breathing
there's something there
get out of there don't even try it with
me i'm way
too pro for you okay there was a hidey
hole
right here you'll never find me hey
hey you guy there don't even think about
telling your money here
don't even think about it don't even
think about it
okay he has no reason to check these
lockers here
no reason
no reason where'd he go what's going on
here
oh he's going ever so slowly
come on man patrol passed just keep
going just keep going that's right
ah that's this stuff go over there oh
yeah
i'm over there oh you almost got me
good work there dumbass
okay yeah yeah i'm oh
i'm so quiet i'm even though i've been
talking for the past 10 minutes
straight i am so quiet for you baby
come on baby come on baby all right
what did that do ah another
decontamination chamber i think that's a
thing that i wanted to open
okay all right all right all right let's
go
let's not go let's not go
let's not go
i don't know if these guys are scripted
or if that was just unlucky
i think that might that had to be
scripted a bit a little bit
oh no you bastard you have no reason to
check here
okay good he didn't check my locker
all right so we gotta sneak past this
guy
ever so quietly
i wish i could crawl faster this is
pretty pathetic
i mean i'm just saying this is pretty
pathetic
what's he doing
what's he doing oh i see what he's doing
why why why man
why did you feel the need to bash down
that door is there something in there
that i need
sometimes in amnesia that would happen
like a monster would just bash down a
random door
okay as long as you don't come this way
man
where'd he go he vanished in the thin
air
he vanished okay
did he vanish did he really vanish or
did i just not see him go somewhere
okay is there anything in here that i
need aha
wait just battery no i can't have been
hit
he didn't vanish i knew he didn't vanish
okay so wait a minute no that was the
other guy oh i wasn't quiet enough for
him
ah okay so now i got two patrolly dudes
or what
what is the deal here i'm so confused
i'm just gonna carry on if that's okay
with you
hello okay
i can make it if i if he comes for me i
can make it right
oh oh get
yeah i was gonna make it the whole time
i wasn't worried even a little bit all
right
all right okay those those guys are
actually a challenge
uh how about you naked guys find some
pants i'm just gonna
put the camera like this for a little
bit
the
how about no why do you guys have
machetes
did you just cut into your hand with a
machete that's
pretty hardcore man that's so metal
all right so uh what exactly do i do
ah you wanna you want some piece of this
you want this
oh you want a piece what
you want a piece i mean you could easily
stab me through the bars right now but
whatever
i'm just gonna not look down for some
strange reason i'm not gonna look
down at you guys okay
so climbing across the ledge then i'm
going to sneak up behind them
and then bash them bash them right in
the back of their heads
and not look at their junk are they
going to pop out of the window that i'm
trying to go to they're going to pop out
aren't they
they're going to pop out
what what do i do are they moving or
what
what's going on where'd they go
okay can i get in there how do i get in
there
looks like a place that i wanted there
we go okay
so i'm now in here uh battery i'm up to
eight of ten i'm doing great on the
batteries
so uh so unlike i'm an amnesia of me
okay so what do we got here proper purge
gate maintenance is crucial to project
wall rider security please refer to
murkoff court maintenance manual blah
blah blah
guys okay so something about maintenance
of the security gate
so i'm assuming that i need that for
that
i don't know there wasn't exactly a clue
in there
so i can go through there
oh good i want to go in the showers
that seems like a great idea when
there's two big naked merly guys around
okay all right
oh man i didn't get that on camera but
i'm pretty sure it was pretty horrific
he just ripped his head off that was
that big guy that threw me out the
window the one that goes little piggy
oh good now i can go take a shower
okay all right okay all right
all right okay what is going on
i think things are rising to a fever
pitch
exit through the showers how
how do i do that thing that you want me
to do
oh it's dark oh it's dark
oh it's raining good dark and stormy
night just what i wanted
okay that's just a curtain fluttering
the breeze
can i get out
yeah i do oh yeah
i didn't even know that i was hiding
from you guys
i didn't even know you were behind me
would you remind me the whole time
where are you hey holes where are you
stupid
naked a-holes
they're messing with me they're not fear
it's not fear these guys
these guys are just [ __ ] around with
me
ah naked joke all right okay
so did i just go in a big circle
i went in a big circle what the heck
what the hell
well all right then where am i supposed
to go
where am i supposed to go where am i
what am i supposed to do was i supposed
to do something else on
oh okay i thought that was a thing ah
i appear to be i don't know why i
couldn't have just jumped down it's not
like the ground is that far away
i would jump out there just to be able
to get the
frickin frack out of here okay there had
to be something else that i could do
i can't really see let me try going left
nope there's a barrier okay so i went
through there
where do i need to go i'm a little
confused then my battery's almost dead
okay this need to get
to there how do i get to there
there was there a way to drop down i
just have no idea i'm totally at a loss
okay i am thoroughly lost for the moment
but
you know what it's actually just about
time to quit so i will figure this out
so that i can move forward
in the meantime so that you guys don't
have to see me flailing around like an
idiot so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations no don't rain batteries
oh i didn't need to do that i meant to
put the camera down
okay all right thank you guys all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that i've done
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
baby
waiting in the bathroom for me to pop
out well i
got you i do reload
reload reload reload reload reload
ah no no no no no no dude